Speaker 1: Herschel Walker held some sort of a
press conference yesterday. Whenever he does this,
it's a very, very bad idea. And during this press
conference, he denies yet another abortion claim.
Remember, a second woman has come forward
saying he urged me to get an abortion. He
paid for it. I didn't want to do it. After going
to the clinic, he went back with me the next day
to make sure that I got that abortion. Herschel
Walker denies it, never particularly credibly,
and then also says he didn't kill JFK. Kind of
making light or making fun of the mere allegation
here as it is, as if it would be equivalent
to accusing him of killing JFK. And you see
in the background over Walker's left shoulder,
if you're watching, that's Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham. We'll get to him and his role in
all of this in a moment. Lindsey just laughs at
the entire thing right here with me all day.
Speaker 4: Well, right now, you know,
guys, I'm done with this foolishness.
Unidentified: I've already told you there's a
line I'm not going to entertain. They contain the.
Speaker 4: Exterior lie alone. And I also want to
let you know, I didn't kill JFK right now.
Speaker 1: Lindsay really liked that one.
I didn't kill JFK either.
Speaker 3: Oh.
Speaker 4: He got
crushed. And they can be. Now, the.
Speaker 1: Democrats who do it say
whatever the by the way, Walker is saying
that he crushed Warnock at the debate where
Walker pulled out a fake badge in the wind.
Speaker 4: It might win this seat, but I want
them to know they don't know Herschel Walker. They
don't know that I'm right here in Georgia and I'm
going to win this seat. I told him when I got in
this race, I'm going to win. They now see that I
am going to win. So I did what you gotta know that
just right here, right now. I'm waiting to see. So
I think that one, I'm not likely to.
Speaker 1: This. This, of course,
has nothing to do with WARNOCK. This has to
do with now multiple women who accuse Herschel
Walker of the exact same thing going former.
Speaker 3: You unequivocally deny you've never
paid for any woman to have an abortion.
So I've seen this movie before, folks. I
remember the Kavanaugh storyline really well.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Lindsey Graham is completely
pathetic. And again, all of the denials are
really not very credible. Here is one from Fox
News yesterday where Brett Beyer asks Herschel
Walker, are you saying you don't even know the
person making the allegations? And Walker simply
says it's a lie, not a very strong denial. And
remember, this is how it started with the first
woman. With the first woman. Walker was asked,
do you even acknowledge knowing the
woman? And he said, I have no idea.
And then it was. Well, yes, I do know the woman.
Well, yes, I did send her the money. Well, yes,
I do have a kid with the woman, but I never urged
her to get an abortion. So this is this is his
denial. You tell me how credible this is.
Speaker 4: All right. Well, this was Gloria
Allred came forward with this client.
You're saying you don't know this person.
What I'm saying and this is alive and.
Speaker 1:
Well, that's a different question.
Speaker 4: I've said it once and I've
moved all my campaign.
Speaker 1: He said it
once about a different woman we've.
Speaker 4: Known because we're worried about
what educated people are talking about. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Not particularly convincing denials.
But then maybe the wackiest part of this entire
thing was when Lindsey Graham got involved.